geared away from that and I focus more  on my domination so domination is is  kind of your  that's where you fit the best  oh yeah  very mean  really  very mean what's the meanest you've  gotten with one of your clients oh man I  mean public humiliations one of them  walking them down a city straight or the  leash really and on their hands and  knees and nothing but underwear  and then anyone willing Who's Laughing  either kick them while we walk by or  spit on them  and you you enjoy this oh yes it is so  fun because I have the power like you  are you're nothing you're on my you're  you're at the bottom of my foot you're  literally at that level you are nothing  and it's great because you're also  paying me to remind you that you're  nothing